how's gone with my name welcome back tom
Nisha
the Dark Descent I hope everything is
working correctly I can back that oh oh
Jesus Christ red goo why did I ever do
to you
keep rhyming today's awesome alright use
the box as they said oh did I not rich
please I use the boxes that's bullcrap
I don't pretend you're what uh what are
you doing there what the [ __ ] why the
hell did you don't look at me
it's like I'm gonna go [ __ ] now I saw
him that [ __ ] all right well whoa
whoa whoa
nope dude shut up closet no one likes
you man I hate you from what you did
last time closet I am not forgetting
closet Oh
these boxes are your friend closet ha ha
ha
they come wait with me you stay here all
alone a closet alameen boxes will never
talk to you you little [ __ ] stupid ass
alright that's about it for the boxes
this is totally how I intended it to be
to be way but stop I'm standing on the
[ __ ] box don't piss me off go
don't you [ __ ] bucks man shut up you
shut up
I'm pissed now books useless yeah
Jesus Christ is [ __ ] boxes I never
thought you bounced pretty well no no no
no what's happening sounded diversion oh
no come on dear Oh weary
oh yeah no no I can't do it daddy
yeah all day that's right superpower I'm
back [ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah whoa whoa
I'm Allah it's America
damn your louse now you have to carry
out [ __ ] you rapes me hey where am I
what the [ __ ]
okay yep it's time to go back and bounce
oh [ __ ] you man
not cool I am on the boxes it's gonna
hurt out out getting raped by blood
again that's not love Leo I need one
more
I don't like the smaller ones that's
what she said all right perfect
oh wow get down
ah ah I [ __ ] hate you how did I ever
do to you except loving
ow ow ow get down what do you want from
me
oh they sink in holy [ __ ] my son it is
like on I am NOT that acrobatic man
all right box I need you there we go
it's like Oh baby girl I'll rock your
world I call you oh hey hey you are a
nope
this is way too difficult
damn it get up you piece of [ __ ]
but don't tell me what to do I'm gonna
let whoa
if I were to sleep for five seconds and
I sleep for five seconds all right back
no no you [ __ ] hell thing all right
here we go
almost there no no don't
whoa harsh it I can't all right this is
the last one I'll ever years yes way out
ah come on oh come on don't hit the door
don't hit the door don't hit the door
don't you do it
nope I'm saying here come on seriously
it's like the most difficult thing in
the world really don't mock me great GU
my insanity is so [ __ ] low at least I
have oil not anymore
are we good I don't trust this one
second what what wind thank you kind of
nice makes my nipples hard okay I don't
even have tender boxes unfortunately we
have to go down back here where the
padlock is and then we're gonna use the
chipper on it but I don't like this
who's that my insanity is so freakin low
holy [ __ ] I think it's over here nope
maybe over here nope yes here it is
alright please work yes oh my god
I'm safe or am I
nope that's going on here
I mean I really I don't need it your oh
no no no no no no no okay now pull back
you come in with me man
[ __ ] where have you been all my life you
know I takin [ __ ] and stuff
to be continued ah no not here
dude the dude okay that's the short head
credit but anyway like a baby as you
enjoy it it's gotta come bro today and
I'll see you next episode of what I have
tried to me that's pretty much what
sorry guy
whoa not front-flip don't here we go
here we go